pierre naville dix ans après la
catastrophe nucléaire à chaque soir sa
terrible révélation sur la véritable
chape de plomb qui a suivi cet accident
et ses conséquences meurtrières
aujourd'hui le reporter se sont rendus
en belarus la république frontalière de
l'ukraine ou poussés par le vent 70% des
radiations se sont déposés sur la terre
contaminant les cultures et par voie de
conséquence d'alimentation d'un pays qui
n'a pas les moyens financiers de
procéder à une véritable décontamination
jose dans la pierre jean françois roy
seul et que mariah va donner à ces
enfants est devenu suspect depuis que le
nuage de tchernobyl est passé au dessus
de son de l'âge alors maria le fait
contrôlé deux fois par an seulement
la dernière fois c'était il ya un mois
ils étaient contaminés à cause du foin
qu'elle avait donné à sa vache
bon on l'a vu quand même on l'a pas
donnée aux enfants mais on nous a dit
que les adultes nouvelle mois voici la
grand mère de maria sur sa terre
contaminée 7 bat boutique à vis comme
avant l'accident
les mesures de radioactivité importe peu
pour elle ça ne sert à rien de se voir
parce que nous n'allons pas déménager
moi je ne partirai pas nous sommes en
belarus la frontière avec l'ukraine
n'est pas loin tchernobyl n'est qu'à une
centaine de kilomètres
c'est dans cette région que l'accident a
eu le plus de conséquences
alors dans ce bois qui sert à chauffer
la maison il ya aussi un risque de
contamination
ce jour-là un expert nucléaire français
rendez visite à la ferme pour un
contrôle
en fait ce sont les cendres qui
l'intéressent contamination décembre
fait partie des problèmes en territoires
contaminés
le risque d'exposition qui en résulte et
la dispersion de césium dans
l'environnement et notamment dans le
jardin potager puisque les cendres sont
souvent utilisés comme engrais dans ce
jardin potager
il explique aussi que la radioactivité
s'est réparti sur le sol sous forme de
tâches comme une peau de panthère et que
dans l'échantillon mesurer le risque est
faible
je suis pas sûr et puis ça m'est égal
dans ce village les habitants n'ont
appris la contamination que deux ou
trois ans après l'accident
quelques familles ont déménagé fisel
sont revenus faute d'argent
faute d'avoir trouvé mieux en bélarus
une personne sur cinq vit sur une terre
empoisonné par les retombées de
tchernobyl